en 2021 la Commission européenne a
financer une campagne de communication
sur le voile islamique qui affirmait
notamment que je cite la liberté et dans
le hijab ces mots sont injustifiables à
l'heure où tant de femmes en Iran et
dans le monde risque leur vie sont tués
parce qu'elles résistent à l'oppression
qui leur est imposée le message de
l'Europe ne peut consister à leur
répondre c'était l'un des slogans
apportés de la joie accepter le hijab
notre Parlement doit exiger la fin
immédiate de toute communication de ce
type nous le devons à la mémoire de
Marsa Amini de toutes les femmes qui ont
été tuées de celles qui risquent leur
vie aujourd'hui justement au nom de la
liberté avec de nombreux collègues de
notre groupe nous souhaitons vous
proposer cet amendement
[Applaudissements]